Videoma sponsor olduğu için 6365'e teşekkür ederiz.
İzlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.
Altyum Designer
Sizi fikirden üretime kadar elektronik üretim sürecinin her detayına sorunsuz bir şekilde bağlayan sezgisel bir arayüzle zahmetsizce PCB tasarımları oluşturun.
Altium 365
Platforma sorunsuz bir şekilde entegre olduğundan ek lisans gerektirmeden ekstra kurulum veya yapılandırmaya ihtiyaç duymadan Altium Designer içinden zahmetsizce tasarlayın, paylaşın ve üretin.
Herhangi bir tarayıcı ya da cihazdan gelen geri bildirimleriyle zamandan tasarruf edelim.
Octopart elektronik parçalar ve bileşenler için ücretsiz bir arama motorudur.
Dünya çapında 16 milyondan fazla kullanıcı artık Octopart'a güveniyor.
Videonun açıklamalar kısmında bulunan bağlantıları kullanarak bu ücretsiz uygulamaları denemekten ve kullanmaktan çekinmeyin.
İzlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.